one of the biggest surprises in
Transformers rise of the Beast could
foreshadow and Autobots fate for
Transformers movies going forward
warnings spoilers ahead as the seventh
installment in a live-action
Transformers film franchise rise of the
Beast needs to have a few surprises up
his sleeves to keep audiences invested
the new movie accomplishes there's
pretty much right away in the first
battle between the autobots and the
terracons Not only does Scourge wind up
with half of the transwarp key by the
end but he also kills fan favorite
bumblebee in the process it's an intense
development especially seeing how he was
the star of his own spin-off film and
appeared in the Michael Bay Transformers
movies which are presumably in the same
universe as rise of the Beast
fortunately Optimus Prime and his team
bring Bumblebee's body with them on
their Adventure when they go to Peru
they find the mountains are filled with
Energon in its inert form it's not
enough to revive bumblebee but once a
final climactic battle kicks off an
explosion is enough to jumpstart the
Energon and resurrect bumblebee
bumblebee gets 11 of the day berta's
Revival make come as a surprise a long
time Transformers fans and it opens up
the possibility that it wasn't Energon
at all and was instead something far
more Sinister that could function in
further sequels Energon has been around
pretty much as long as Transformers
itself it not only functions as a
Transformer's primary fuel source but
it's been used to power weapons and as a
type of currency it's a casual item that
can take on many forms based on the
needs of the plot
once the septicons nearly held the
quadrant through Terror now we scrap
like slags over a few Energon cubes it
should even be familiar to people whose
only understanding of Transformers comes
from the live-action films Megatron is
killed in the first Transformers when
some whitwicky seemingly kills the evil
Transformer with the all-spark cube but
the Decepticon is revived in Revenge of
the Fallen thanks to a small fragment
from the old spark that still contained
Energon generating properties
from here we leave the comfort of the
bay verse and jump into the world of
Transformers lore Energon usually exists
as fuel or electricity it's even the
blood found in Autobots that
occasionally squared South after
sustaining and nasty injury and while
the old Sparks Energon was used to
revive Megatron before it's still
surprising that's how it was used for
Bumblebee and it's possible there's
another substance out there that could
put the Autobots In Harm's Way the dark
energy name suggests is a polar opposite
of good old-fashioned Energon it's a
corrupting substance that makes anyone
who ingests it more powerful and
aggressive there's also an addictive
property where the dark Energon user has
to continually take more and more of the
material or else they'll descend into
madness and eventually die also like
Energon this substance has a myriad of
uses from corrupting Autobots to
Reviving The Dead dark Energon was
featured prominently in the 2010 series
Transformers Prime where it was used to
bring the dead back as terracons which
just so happened to be the bad guys in
Rise of the Beast it was easy to miss
the mention of dark energy John in the
film but its abilities are on full
display we even see their corrupting
properties in one of scourge's attacks
hits air razor gradually turning her
evil so it may be possible bumblebee got
a taste of it when he was brought back
to life since regular Energon isn't
typically used to resurrect Autobots it
raises the question of whether that was
indeed plain Energon or if it could have
been the other variety if it was the
latter bumblebee could be secretly
corrupted and descend into madness at a
prospective sequel potentially the
Autobots may have to find the McGuffin
cure to restore bumblebee back to sanity
introducing new story threads for future
installments then again Energon is such
a nebulous plot device it can do pretty
much anything and with that final scene
there may be more than enough for a rise
of the Beast sequel to follow
[Music]